the German language need to be more diverse
no it needs to be more more more more inclusive
yep the German language is very discriminating
what the hell are they talking about
German is that language
when you speak
I would definitely know
if you are talking about your friend guy
or your friend girl
you will be talking of friend or the friend in
I don't do that in English
I just talk of a friend
and they'll be all left hanging wondering
was he female
no German is very specific when it comes to gender
you'll be talking of friend friend in yeah
you'll be talking of Lera de radan
in English just teacher teacher
and that's exactly the problem
maybe I don't want to be identified as female or male
maybe I belong to another gender
have you thought of that
with a million genders out there today
how is a German language supposed to cope with that
but now on a more serious note
I understand where that is coming from
German is a very traditional language
and language
as that has to grow
it has to adapt to society
and German being so traditional
it has some you know
words which don't fit to today's society anymore
words for example
of occupations which were just maybe carried out
back to the day by male
like doctors or pilots you know
these were masculine occupations
and then there were others which were feminine
occupations like cranichester nursing or puth fro
and since today this is not the case anymore
I guess the German language had to someone adopt
you know and just a little bit grow
and the thing that many people have a problem with
is actually in the plural
where the plural of many
words many nouns
is usually the masculine
for example
when you have a group of diverse doctors
it will be deduct one
not you know
the feminine is like left out
you have the leader
yeah it's a group of male and female doctors
by just the male being mentioned
I don't think it ever
ever disturbed anyone
I don't think anyone ever
really felt left out or discriminated
but you know
with a society where everything becomes a problem
for no good reason
it's somehow become a big thing
so no I actually think the German language as it is
is actually very gender conscious
and actually quite diverse